Argentina juega el fénix Polonia pinchó
La burbuja de Arabia Saudita y Francia
logró su revancha Esos son los tres
resultados importantes de esta jornada
con Argentina que se midió aquí en el
estadio del usail ante el actriz ganando
dos goles por Cero en un partido
bastante difícil con muchísimas
interrupciones hasta 16 faltas en tan
solo la primera parte pero Argentina que
sale a flote gracias a dos generalidades
una de Leonel Messi y luego la segunda
de Enzo Fernández en todo caso lo que
ocurre con Argentina que por ahora es
segundo de grupo se va a decir en el
último partido en donde la albi Celeste
se enfrentará a Polonia Polonia que a su
vez ganó hoy a Arabia Saudita dos goles
por cero los saudíes que se tuvieron que
enfrentar ante el muro de El Arquero
polacochesmi y dos goles uno de celenski
y el segundo de lewandowski el 9 que por
fin logra marcar en a un mundial por el
lado de por fin ganaron a Dinamarca dos
goles por uno doblete de mbappé e los
dos hombres que hicieron los pases para
estos goles el primero esteo Hernández y
el segundo es un griezmann y con este
resultado de dos goles por uno pues ya
Francia tiene seis puntos y es la
primera selección aquí en Qatar 2022 en
estar en octavos de final